basically Donald was like oh like right
here first right here and he kisses and
he's like no I think actually it should
be right here and then he proceeds to
he's asking too much yeah what happened
to high five down low too slow
[Music]
all right so this is just something we
just gotta talk about bart actually sent
this over as well he posted it on his
feet it was just some [__] up stuff
you already know where I'm going with
this I don't know and I think you're
lying
how about this your mom says this guy's
a nut case
familiar now oh because a lot of stuff
happens in my day Nick said Nick said
this guy's pretty chill I said this guy
is real oh the Dalai Lama
that was so weird so I mean have you
heard this story I haven't but this is
really [__] up
there's a video that goes goes out where
he's literally um looking at this boy
and he kisses his boy on the lip and
then he proceeds to ask him to suck his
tongue and I'm talking just cameras
there's microphones like it's it's very
it's like a press conference yeah it's
very public oh he has dementia he's
clearly he's an old man maybe he's on
Trent that's a great cover Jordan makes
you very horny we won't show everything
about it because we don't want to get
demonetized so this is a blurred version
um if you can
dude everyone's watching them too
oh so that's that's him kissing him oh
that's a long kiss too why are they why
do they woo like it's Married with
Children
everyone's hyped
and then
this gets weird do you guys see the
video yeah I couldn't watch it yet
oh he did it no he doesn't do it the kid
doesn't do it but he like tries to get
him to do it I like the translator it's
very thorough so here's the thing I
posted about something on my story and I
actually got a bunch of fans that are
Tibetan to tell me that the whole tongue
thing is actually cultural I was gonna
say I don't know anything about the
culture of religion and I'm just like um
I don't know about the tongue sucking I
don't know about that part but like
sticking saying hi to each other it's
supposed to be a very like
um I don't like a friendly thing and
then there's a bunch of other videos of
and photos of him like getting really
close to other people so I guess those
two are it's it's cultural and it's not
supposed to be out of the norm but the
part that makes me feel weird about it
is if it's cultural and not out of the
norm then why when he gets called out
did he not say that and goes I'm sorry I
shouldn't have done that yeah if it's if
it's cultural it would have developed
another name he wouldn't have to say
suck my tongue let's do the thing you
know what I mean it's like it's like
people are like oh sticking their tongue
out that's like kind of cultural normal
suck my tongue I don't know that's like
the same thing as saying like say hi to
somebody with your hands normal but like
if I slap you right after I'll just grab
my nuts yeah or grab the eyes more
directly you know what I mean it's like
those are very different things yeah
Polynesian theme where they go like this
and they share the air here there's a
name for airshare yeah yeah there's a
name for it they don't go like
[Laughter]
like Bart said he does formally
apologize for it which what was he
called out by a reporter from there or
from like the United States or something
the video had leaked and once it went
viral on like the interwebs that's when
everybody started so other people that
aren't from there were the ones so I
don't know if it's like uh he's clearly
like this elder that is respected is
that like a thing I I saw Tibetans
saying that's not normal okay yeah oh
[__] yeah it's like they're conflicted
because they're like yeah we show tongue
but then we don't ask people to suck
yeah he's like the like the Buddhist
Pope yeah so he's like does she speak
English yeah very well very well and
how's that to say suck my tongue yeah
but I didn't know if it was like it was
like a he meant to say something else oh
no he's very good at English yeah well
[__] that's weird as [__] guys
did your mom say that he was a political
puppet yeah so my mom's super into the
boots like my mom's into the Buddhist
world like Steve's into football like
she he knows she knows all the players
she knows the backstory and all that so
when I saw it like
my gut feeling was like what the [__]
this is weird and especially in the last
two or three years we have like the
whole Epstein case coming out and then
we see [__] Joe Biden sniffing little
girls heads and then we just have like a
whole like kind of like an unraveling of
how many Elite people like really like
preying on kids
um so I was like oh [__] is he wanted
this [__] too in this whole like
weird Elite Class right so I was like I
don't want to like misjudge it so I was
like yo mom what do you think she's the
other Buddhist expert that I know and
then the minute she saw that she replied
she goes the Dalai Lama is the devil and
he's actually a political puppet so he's
like someone I believe the second one
but he was like put in there in place I
only believe the first two
um I don't know I and then I started
looking into it it's like I think he was
like CIA yeah we did we did an article
about like the top conspiracy theories
that ended up being true yeah and then
uh like number two was that he was like
a CIA uh he's like a paid person to help
to like destabilize China or something
yeah he's he's like a the tool to like
the global tool to like mess with China
basically yeah through Tibetan like
Independence yeah so I was like I don't
know this is crazy he gets an American
check every year my mom's crazy too so I
don't even know if I should believe her
but she don't get an American check so
you know and she doesn't have people
sucking on her tongue either
I'm not sure I'm not going there I'm not
gonna touch that there's a whole
conspiracy theory about the world's
leaders
um are all like pedals yeah like they
have to be because to be a part of the
club you have to do pedal [__] yeah it
feels like it in order starting to see
it yeah you think you think Dalai Lama
was on the the flight log dude you think
he's going to Epstein Island you don't
know I mean Bill Clinton just rubbing
elbows that's all I gotta say where's
the list you know imagine the list is
just zombie Lama show the list it just
says Dolly love on the paper the guy who
works at Epstein Island he's like yeah
there's a guy in like orange
tree that says suck my tongue it's like
yeah
that's my best best
all this footage is coming out with
Dalai Lama now but one of the funniest
things is um so he's sitting next to
Lady Gaga and she has like those ripped
jeans and he goes to her knee and he
goes
see that's that's weird that's maybe
acceptable yeah but if you're a tongue
sucker then now you're like that's a
little fishy now yeah now it all makes
sense but his body of work does he
believed to be like a reincarnation yeah
I think that's how it's supposed to be
like uh every Dalai Lama they try to
find the kid that reminds you of the
last one and they choose that one it's
supposed to be ANG right you know the
Airbender yeah yeah he's supposed to be
what would you do if historically every
Dalai Lama got their tongue sucked
then that would make more sense yeah it
wouldn't not be sodium at least it's
consistent you know you think the whole
world leader is being pedo thing it's
like like gang initiation [__] like
you're not even let's say yeah let's get
jumped in but you have to you got to do
it that's exactly what I but you down
and then they'll be like not really but
I guess I got to yeah it's kind of like
Will Smith with [__] what was that
one religion the the alien one
Scientology Scientology is he a
Scientologist yeah same with a lot of
Hollywood peoples Tom Cruise or
something like that yeah yeah they all
got to get dirt on each other somehow
but I think the [__] pedest is one of
the craziest ones think about it dude at
that level can you just be like hey
trust me bro and you're like I I'll
Trust you
maybe I guess if the opposition is like
you either gotta kill somebody or do
this to a kid I don't know dude you know
what would you do if it's those choices
what would you do Nick how did you kill
somebody dude what was your kid you guys
but if you kill someone you're out of
the club wait I thought you said it's
either kill somebody or that's what I'm
saying it's one of the other it's like
is there a lesser evil that you would do
in order to Hold Your Position to power
that's not the good choice it's the only
option is the only option thank you Ryan
thank you position of Power are they
gonna that's what I'm saying like in a
Murk your ass when they find they tell
you is this a collateral I think it's
collateral right it's like they need to
have some dirt on you to know that
you're in but not but now you know that
they're touching kids and if you say no
they're gonna murk your ass right
basically
yeah because you know play ball dude I
gotta play ball that's how these guys
end up here probably you trying to get
killed I don't know about that try to
drink baby blood dude absence house in
New York they had cameras rigged all
over and mad tapes of just people that
they were recording so then they're
saying that that's how they
um have all these world leaders in their
back pocket yeah and then that's why
they won't release the list because it's
like too many people are involved so if
the list goes they're like we're all
gonna be [__] conspiracy theories are
fun guys I know it's the best part of
the show actually do you think that
Dalai Lama has good Androgen receptors
I don't know about that you're a little
skinny
that's who looks like you got low teeth
yeah he just goes I know his robe comes
off and he's like what if what if
sucking his tongue is the key to eternal
life though I'll talk the [__] out of it
I'll suck that [__] we just denied that
boy like eternal life by going ooh what
if sucking his tongue can give us the
biggest like craziest strengths
that was [__] crazy though that video
yeah and the kid like I've seen an
unblurred version and you see the kid
feel how awkward that whole situation
yeah he pulls himself away if he feels
awkward then it's for sure enough
culture act like this yeah even the kiss
felt awkward and he was just like
I don't know I just well in the in the
official accounting of it basically what
happened was the kid wanted a acid Dalai
Lama if he could have give him a hug
it's always how it starts and then
basically Donald was like oh like right
here first right here and he kisses and
he's like no I think actually it should
be right here and then he proceeds to
damn he's asking too much yeah what
happened to high five down low too slow
yeah whatever this one oh you got
somebody on your shirt yeah some basics
how about I unzip my pants
honestly random kids try to like hug me
I'm like don't even touch me I'm like no
no stop playing hey yeah I don't like
that [__] get your stink ass kid ass he
just did the opposite he did the full
opposite
make out with me
180 that kid went straight to first base
in front of everybody yeah that's what's
crazy how old is he is he old is he that
old where he could get away with that
senile [__] oh like like act like it's
the best yeah I don't know let's say the
kid did suck on his tongue oh do you
think the people that are defending him
now would still defend him
oh if the kid did it but the kid did
suck on it do you think that'd be like
oh that's cultural I think I think a lot
of people will find reasons to back him
up and a lot of people will find reasons
to be like [__] this guy I think that's
what's gonna happen yeah I mean because
people ride for him hard people do right
yeah if he honestly if you ask me in
front of all those people I would like
think about it for a second but I
wouldn't do it who rides for the Dalai
Lama I don't know one person I think
about it I don't know nobody if that's
like if if all these people are claiming
that it's cultural normal I better see
hell hell kids sucking no no I'm going
to the BET right now and I'm gonna be
like because all the ladies whatever
they'll say hello because that [__]
should have gone out way sooner if
they've been doing it for 100 years yeah
like come on that's true because like
there's a thing you do that I know we
know about the Eskimo thing yeah I've
never even seen it like yeah the one
Butterfly Kisses anymore and that's a
problem what's that one where you do
your eyelashes
come on
he's got short ass eyelashes it would
never works you could never satisfy me
with those eyelashes this was done up
high down a little too slow
[Music]
foreign